wie bereitet sich die polizei dann auf
solch eine situation vor die polizei
wird in jedem fall mit etwa 3.000
beamten morgen die hauptstadt schützen
und es wurde heute schon in der
pressekonferenz gesagt sie wird
keinerlei gewalt dulden
ich habe vorher mit einem polizisten
gesprochen und gefragt wie er so die
stimmung einschätzt und er hat gesagt es
ist ein blick in die glaskugel es kann
keiner sagen was morgen passieren wird
es bleibt spannend
man weiß es nicht wie viele denn
wirklich mobilisiert werden im endeffekt
ein grund für dieses große
polizeiaufkommen ist natürlich dass in
sozialen netzwerken vor allem in dem
messenger dienst telegramm massiv zur
gewalt aufgerufen wurde
ich habe selber in diesem thema in
telegramm mitgelesen und das was ich
gelesen habe war doch beängstigend da
wird dann aufgerufen polizisten zu
lynchen mit journalisten soll das am
liebsten das gleiche passieren und es
wird auch dazu aufgerufen waffen
mitzubringen denn die seien jetzt
nämlich erlaubt alles in allem an weiß
es nicht die polizei ist aber gut
vorbereitet auf wahrscheinlich jede
situation und wenn wir jetzt mal einen
kleinen blick nach hier drüben werften
dann sehen wir schon oder bekommen wir
einen kleinen einblick was den morgen
passieren kann hier hinter mir haben
sich etwa schon 150 bis 200 leute
versammelt vor der russischen botschaft
wenn du mich fragen würdest wer
demonstriert denn da ganz schwierige
frage es ist eine mischung aus
verschwörungstheoretikern es sind die
sogenannten reichs bürger unterwegs es
werden allerhand es werden allerhand
kruder theorien verbreitet es werden
auch viele antisemitische theorien
verbreitet über die jüdische
weltverschwörung und man ist jetzt
souverän etc pp
also es bleibt abzuwarten was ich sagen
kann an die hygieneregeln wird sich hier
auf keinen fall gehalten